barca
dacca parce que j'y vais depuis des
années que je chante on chez moi et mes
albums sont sortis là bas je me plante
concernant ben barka à la kasbah j'adore
la zumba j'adore courir j'ai marqué
j'aime bien on the voice c'est pas
forcément une poupée obligé si tu te
maquilles un peu tu peux les hommes vous
avez beaucoup de trucs d'autres atouts
pour pouvoir plaire aux veaux par
exemple et bâle et berne phone on a ce
truc là mais c'est une manière de se
préparer le prendre soin de soi ça
dépend quoi j'aime genre
genre un fight guys un burger king dont
je suis très bas regarde ton
une bonne crise a franchement une bonne
pizza ça n'a pas de prix
dans ce cas maintenant j'aime bien j'ai
bien sûr tout je suis pas je suis pas
tous les matchs gens devant ma télé non
mais non jeu franchement je suis
beaucoup de jeunes vient juste et coupe
du monde parce qu'il était un bloc mais
mes gens comme tout
de plus pour racheter je dors plus mûr
les poils base à des bons chez qui j'ai
dans mon cas c'est une vie passée notre
c'est notre édile sera nous